a startling new study completely changes
what we know about the Tyrannosaurus Rex
researchers found that t-rex could not
really run its size and weight would
have made that nearly impossible hmm
Jonathan Vigliotti is that the t-rex
exhibit in London with how fast the
dinosaurs could actually go Jonathan
good morning good morning the Train
asaurus rex is what's known here at
London's Natural History Museum as an
apex predator meaning anything standing
in its way could become its breakfast
fortunately for these visitors he's just
a robot but even if he was real new
science suggests to avoid being eaten
all you need to do is simply run away
[Music]
it's one of cinema's classic scenes an
angry t-rex charges at a group of
terrified researchers in Steven
Spielberg's Jurassic Park
but the stuff of sci-fi legend could
really just be fiction new science
saying the mighty t-rex could barely run
at all t-rex was quite a lot slower than
people have thought professor William
sellers who led this study says the
prehistoric beast was so big its legs
would have buckled under the high speeds
of 45 miles per hour it was once
believed to run the problem with that is
that running that fast it actually
breaks all the bones in its legs there
are lots of people who would love to
believe that t-rex was the stuff of
nightmares and that was running around
and in this enormous animal and you have
to bring a bit of reality into it
Sellars research at the University of
Manchester analyzed the Treynor sources
bone size density and movement to
determine the t-rex was limited to
walking speeds an unflattering
simulation shows the prehistoric beast
is less stealth predator and more
awkward Park jogger at its fastest an
adult t-rex can only reach about 12
miles per hour left in the dust by
Olympian Usain Bolt who can run 20 miles
per hour even the average human is
faster I was a little bit disappointed I
have to say I mean not necessarily
surprised but I think I was hoping for a
bit to be a bit quicker but the new
research has rocked the science
community and the way we understand the
monsters of our past says dr. Paul
Barrett maybe they're not fast enough to
be a predator at all and that maybe
they're restricted to being in scavenger
on some of the big carcasses it would
have been littering the environment
a scavenger doesn't fit Hollywood's
image of the ruler of the rock
[Music]
predator verse scavenger at this point
still unclear though the t-rex says hold
one key title at least for now
scientists believe he had the strongest
jaw of any animal to ever roam earth ten
times more powerful than the alligator
viana he said tell my five-year-old he's
faster than a t-rex great news Jonathan
Vigliotti thank you strong jaw but not
that's be exactly